No.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
How did Greek influence English?
That is the question.
As I mentioned in my recent video on the
Greek language,
Greek is a language that has influenced
many others including English.
The most remarkable way that Greek has
influenced English isn't it's
vocabulary.
In my previous video,
I briefly mentioned that around six
percent of the vocabulary of English is
of Greek origin,
but that some estimates reach as high as
12 or 15 percent.
This depends on how you measure it.
You can measure type frequency,
the percentage of the total number of
words with no regard for how often
they're used or you can measure a token
frequency,
meaning the proportion of words in a
given speech or text,
so words that are more frequently used
account for a larger proportion.
There's a huge number of words of Greek
origin that are used in specialized
areas of the sciences,
medicine,
and technology that aren't used very
often in regular speech.
So if we measure type frequency,
the percentage of Greek words will be
higher because less common words are
given equal weight.
If we measure a token frequency,
the percentage will be lower because
less common words are counted less.
I believe that the figure of six percent
is based on token frequency and the
higher figures are based on type
frequency.
Some Greek words were borrowed directly
from Greek into English.
Some of these were borrowed early in the
history of English like church from the
Greek word [inaudible],
which entered old English as cute chick
and some were borrowed later in the
early modern English period.
For example,
autonomy.
This word entered English directly from
ancient Greek out to nomia in the 16
twenties,
but a larger number of Greek words
entered English indirectly through Latin
or through Latin than French.
For example,
museum.
This comes from the Latin word
[inaudible],
meaning library or study,
and that comes from the ancient Greek
word Moose sale,
which meant place of study,
library,
museum,
or school of art or poetry.
And if we go back even further to the
original meaning of the ancient Greek
word,
it meant the seat or shrine of the
muses.
The nine muses were the daughters of
Zeus in the Masani.
They were goddesses who symbolized the
arts and sciences.
Another example,
the word olive entered the English
language around the twelfth century ce,
either from old French bullies or
directly from Latin Oliva or Oliva,
which in turn comes from the Greek word
a lie.
Well,
the word chaos comes from the Greek word
cows and entered English in the 14th
century via Latin than French
catastrophe entered English and the 15
thirties from Latin catastrophe from the
Greek word catastrophe,
which was originally pronounced as
cholesterol pay,
meaning and overturning or a sudden end.
The word democracy entered English in
the 15 seventies.
It came from the middle French word.
They mccloskey which in turn came from
medieval Latin Democrat,
which came from ancient Greek.
The word paragraph entered English in
the late 14,
hundreds via medieval Latin and French,
and it comes from the Greek word
[inaudible],
which was originally pronounced as
paddock it.
I pause and there are many more words
like this,
the largest number of Greek words to
enter English.
We're actually newly created words.
They were newly created using Greek
morphemes,
but they're words that hadn't existed in
Greek before that point.
And then those words were borrowed from
Latin into English.
Some are formed from only Greek
morphemes,
for example,
photography.
This word was created in 1834 by
combining photo,
which meant lights in ancient Greek and
the ancient Greek suffix graffel meaning
to scratch or to scrape,
but later meaning to right.
And if you're wondering how those
different meanings are related to scrape
and to write well,
think about how people used to write
thousands of years ago.
They used to scrape letters into stone
tablets.
Another word,
xenophobia or xenophobia.
This word was created in 19 Oh,
three from the Greek root,
phenols meaning alien and phobia,
meaning fear.
Other words were formed from a
combination of both Greek and Latin
morphemes.
For example,
television.
This word was created from the Greek
morpheme t lay meaning far or at a
distance.
And the French word,
Vco meaning site.
This word entered English via French.
Another example,
automobile.
The first part comes from ancient Greek
autos,
meaning self.
And the second part comes from the
French word [inaudible],
which means moving,
which came from Latin moby.
These movable sociology.
The first part comes from the Latin word
Celsius,
meaning comrade,
and the second part comes from the Greek
morpheme loggia,
meaning discourse.
Now just have a look at them morphemes
that are highlighted.
You've probably seen many more words
that feature these same Greek morphemes.
There are lots of common Greek roots in
English,
for example,
and throat meaning man,
crone or Chron,
meaning time them meaning people,
head meaning child.
There are also many Greek affixes app or
an meaning without by or bio meaning
life or living thing,
hyper meaning excessive micro meaning
small geo meaning earth or geography,
anti meaning against it,
a suffix that forms adjectives and many
more.
A huge number of these newly coined
words exist in areas of academia,
medicine,
science,
and technology because the huge
advancements in these areas over the
past 500 years required the creation of
lots of new vocabulary in the field of
medicine.
For example,
Latin words,
both old and new,
newly coined ones were often used for
anatomy.
While Greek words were used for the
names of illnesses or specializations.
A lot of these specialized words are not
used in daily conversation very often,
but without them it will be very
difficult to talk about these advanced
fields of study.
It's also worth noting that these words
are not exclusive to English.
A lot of them are used in other
languages as well when talking about
those fields of study.
Here are a couple of hints on how to
recognize Greek vocabulary.
Most words starting with Ph are Greek.
Some vowels,
spellings give us a hint like aee or
oee.
Together,
if you see a wide between consonants,
it's likely a Greek word.
If a word starts with any of these
consonant clusters,
then it's almost certainly a word of
Greek origin.
Some of these clusters can't be
pronounced in English like ps or pen or
Gen.
so the first letter is dropped in
pronunciation.
An interesting example back in the 19
fifties,
professor sandol phones,
the Lotus,
a Greek economist and the 75th prime
minister of Greece gave two speeches in
which she addressed the audience in
English,
but using exclusively words of Greek
origin with the exception of grammar,
words like articles,
prepositions and conjunctions.
All of the content where it's wearing
Greek here is a piece of one of those
speeches which he gave to the
International Bank for Reconstruction
and development.
It is Zeus and that's them up on our
epoch for the dynamism of our economies
and the heresy of our economic methods
and policies that we should agonize
between the seller of numismatic
plethora and the curb dis of economic
anemia.
It is not my idiosyncrasy to be ironic
or sarcastic,
but my diagnosis would be that
politicians are rather crypto plethora
wrists,
although they emphatically stigmatized
numismatic plethora,
energize it through their tactics and
practices.
Our policies have to be based more on
economic and less on political criteria.
Now,
let's break that down a little bit.
The first part it is Zeus is anathema on
our epoch.
This means it is [inaudible] curse or a
punishment on our time or era.
In a typical English sentence,
you might expect to see God in this
context instead of Zeus,
for the dynamism of our economies and
the heresy of our economic methods and
policies.
Here,
he's saying that Zeus is punishment,
is for the uncontrolled activity of our
economies and our economic heresy,
meaning violating,
accepted economic ideas,
and next he'll explain what the
punishment is that we should agonize
between the seller of numismatic
plethora and the coverup this of
economic anemia.
Now these two words here,
Scylla and Charybdis,
these are actually characters from Greek
mythology.
They are to mythical sea monsters,
too dangerous monsters that it's
difficult to navigate between because if
you move away from one,
you move toward the other.
Their names here are indicating to
dangerous situations,
so the first of those two dangerous
situations is numismatic plethora.
Numismatic means related to coins or
currency and plethora means abundance or
a lot of these two words together,
me and inflation,
meaning there's too much currency in
circulation,
so prices increase.
And the second dangerous situation,
the curb,
this is economic anemia.
Anemia meaning stagnation or loss of
energy.
Most of the second part is probably
easier to understand,
but let's look at one part,
but my diagnosis would be that
politicians are rather crypto plethora,
wrists.
Now this word requires a look.
Crypto means secret and plethora.
Wrists,
remember that word before Plethora,
which means abundance or a lot of,
and then it's.
That's an affix showing the dewar of an
action.
So Plethora.
Wrists are people who create an
abundance of money.
They create inflation,
although they emphatically stigmatize
numismatic plethora,
although they speak badly about
inflation,
they energize it through their tactics
and practices.
He's saying that politicians are
secretly creating inflation despite what
they say.
That's just an excerpt,
but I'll leave a link to the full
version of the two speeches in the
description below.
Now,
the irony of me describing that speech
in standard English is that I've
probably used a lot of words of Greek
origin myself without realizing it.
So the question of the day,
were you surprised to discover how much
English vocabulary comes from Greek?
Were you surprised by any of the
examples?
Also,
feel free to leave additional examples
in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again,
thank you to all of my amazing patrion
supporters for their monthly pledges,
especially these people right here on
the screen.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.